TEACHES RACIAL SLURS AND THAE WK
DISNEY MOVIE TELHESTORY OF RUBX
YELD FIRST
ARACHE INTEGRATED AND
WHITE ELRY SCHOOL
ORLEANSN . IT IS NOW THE
INSTRUCT AS THE
STATE OFRIDA LS HOW
ON ON RACE, SEXUALITY AND
ER TAUGHT IN  PG RATED MOVIE ISW
SCHOOLS INLORIDA APLAINT BY AREH
LI OF APPROVED FILMS.
NORTH SHORE ELEME
COMPLAINT FTHS REDAC
NO SPELLING OUT
OBJEIO TO USL
PEOPLE AS PROPRIATE F EE
PARENTS HAVE OBJECTY BRIDGS TAUT
IN THE CLASSROOMN
THIS CURRICULUM HIGHLIGHTS ISLL
THE MEAN WHITE PEOEOWIZED
SHARE INN I
THESE BOOKS I SHAREURHIOROD A'SE
YEAR, ACCORDING TO THE FLORIDA
NOW GO THRORMALEST OF THE YEARSL
OBJECTION PROCESS TO REVIIAL PER
ICYORD ON HOW
THE REVIEW WILL TAKE TO
COMPLETE. A HERE.HIS
IS THE SAMERI THAT
BLUEST E WHEOURED NOBELNNING AUM
COMPLAINEDND ITEWED FROM IN
JANUARY BOOK PULLED
LIBRARIES.
LISTEN THIAGO, THANK YOU SO MUCD
IS YOUR REACTION TFILM NOWA. IK
UNFORTUNATE. I
BAD THATNE PARENT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO STOP. OER SEEIN FHE
HE. UM AND I TNKERREACTION. BUTS
T SINGECSHEOK AND THE
MOVEMENTPARENTSELY, UM, TOWER.
YOU SAID WEREIXTHAT I WHEN YOU E
THATAYO THIS PARE WRA YOU T
SECOND GRADEINNDE
TEACHERS T
TEACHERSA L.
GRADERSRE ENOTO WHATO BE CALLES
LEARN ABOUT THE
CI I AAT
THISEAY D TO
IS APPARENT FEELI ED TO
OR HER WILL OTHER
PARENTSOT WANWKIDS IN
THEIR CLASS. TELL
THAT WAY.XPANDE
EWOWAUSTORE PARENTSS
MOVEMENT, WHICH I THINK IS
CIN OF THE
THCLUSIVENSTRUCTIONINGT ACE
ABIDETHAT. MY PARENTS THINKHI TS
WEREN'TO THATHIS IS AVI BLACK
PARENTS DONAVE. BLACKPARENTREN'Y
CAN WATC FORR.HA
IV
HAD TO WATCH A LOT OFHIAT I D LT
HAVE THAT CHOI. A
BOOK THE ADVENTURESTHERE W
YOUR DIDT OU'RE
AS A
CO, YOU DIDN'T READ
OU WERE T
ANOTHER AREA WHEN THAT BOOK WAG
TO OPT
L FOR ME,
AND ,UTLDOT
SAY COOK,
BUT WE T PARENTAL
THERWAWO. WE DIDT THOSEIG
N
RENT TIME. BUT I YNOPARENTME THN
OURO
, ANDFA
CESSAR O ONE
ESAN
KIT'S
. WATCH IT. B
THAT ONLIMITING YOUNG CHILDN'
EXPOSURE TO RACISM? COULD MAKEOA
THEY IFONCATION THEY GET OF SCHY
CANAY DIDTTAND THARA. EXISTS. IS
IN THEIR SCHOOLDS
HELPS
MOVEMENT AND WRE WT
THAT IF THERE NIDE FROM THE BAOA
TRUE. WATCH TE PEOPLE. THELM DOS
DIDN'T HALI AE WERE NO F TED AH